>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, everyone
and thank you all for coming.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb.
And I'm very happy to see you all in
the African - Middle East Division.
I'm addressing you
here in the division
but I'm also addressing all those
who will be watching this program --
not only in the United States
but also across the globe.
And as you know, our
programs are webcast.
And so, thank you for our team
that's webcasting this program.
And we are, today, looking -- we're
going to be looking at a program --
at a subject which is impacting
many, many regions of the world.
The issue of refugees.
And our speaker -- and
I'm -- Dr. Yacob-Haliso --
is going to be addressing one
particular group of refugees.
But what she says has
implications for --
not only Liberia but for
regions across the globe.
And this is why it is
such an important program.
And we're bringing her here -- she
has just flown from Lagos to be
with us and to share her thoughts,
her work, and her research with us.
But let me make a little commercial
for our division as I always do.
The African - Middle East
Division is one of the divisions
of the Library of Congress that
is responsible for the collections
from Africa, from the Middle
East, from Central Asia,
from the Hebraic world, from
78 countries around the globe.
And though these countries
have different languages,
different cultures, different
scripts, they are all united
by a wide range of
issues -- problems.
One of which is the
issue of refugees.
They also are -- we collect from
these countries materials --
not only in English or French,
but the materials in the languages
in which those -- that research
and those books are written.
In other words, this
division is responsible
for at least 35 different
languages from the countries --
from the 78 countries
that we represent.
These materials appear in various
scripts and the collections
that we have focus on
the books, the journals,
the serials, and also ephemera.
Other collections on the
78 countries can be found
across the library.
For example, raw [phonetic]
materials, let's say on Liberia,
will be found in the raw library.
Maps would be found in the
geography and map division.
Music could be found
in the music division.
Recordings -- oral recordings would
be in the American Folk Life Center.
Photographs and prints and posters
would be found in the Prints
and Photographs division.
We also have a very large
directorate for cataloguing all
of these materials
because were we not
to catalogue them, they
would not be found.
We have -- not only a large
cataloguing division and many
of our specialists, expert
cataloguers are present here.
But they're also scholars and
specialists in the languages
and the cultures that we represent.
So, now, we are very much looking
forward to hear Dr. Yacob-Haliso,
but it would be one
of our scholars --
one of the scholars of the African
- Middle East Division, librarian
and scholar, professor, and
wide range was published
in wide range fields,
Dr. Angel Batiste,
who is responsible for West Africa.
And she will be introducing
the speaker today.
So, Dr. Batiste.
[ Applause ]
>> Angel Batiste: Good afternoon.
On behalf of the African section,
on behalf of my colleagues
in the African section, it's a great
pleasure to welcome today's speaker.
We're always extremely pleased
when we can have scholars
from Africa join us here
at the Library of Congress.
And our guest today, she's
just come in from Lagos.
I know she's probably still
a little tired -- jet lagged.
But she has agreed
to be with us today.
So, we thank you.
To introduce our speaker,
Dr. Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso.
And I've been practicing
your name all morning.
So, forgive me if I mispronounce.
But Dr. Yacob-Haliso is a senior
lecturer in political science
at Babcock University
in Ogun State, Nigeria.
She is a current post-doctoral
fellow of the American Council
of Learned Societies -
African Humanities Program.
She has also completed Post-doctoral
research as a Global South Scholar
and Resident at the Graduate
Institute of International
and Development Studies
in Geneva, Switzerland.
Dr. Yacob-Haliso research
has centered on African women
in post-conflict situations,
refugees and forced migration,
gender and politics, and
democracy in Nigeria.
She has been the recipient
of research grants
from the Harry Frank
Guggenheim Foundation,
the Canadian International
Development Research Center,
the International Development
Research Council, the University
for Peace, Africa Program;
and the African Association
of Political Science.
Dr. Yacob-Haliso has
authored numerous articles
in various international journals.
And she is the current
editor of the Journal
of International Politics
and Development.
She is a member of the West Africa
Political Science Association,
The Liberian Studies Society
for Peace Studies and Practice,
the Council for the Development of
Social Sciences Research in Africa,
the West African Political
Science Association,
and the Global South Caucus of the
International Studies Association.
Dr. Haliso, we welcome you.
[ Applause ]
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso:
Thank you, Dr. Batiste,
for the kind introduction.
And I want to also thank the head of
African and Middle Eastern division
of the Library of Congress,
Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb
for granting me the
opportunity to speak
at this noon time symposium series.
And thank you all for
coming out this afternoon --
at your lunch time -- to
listen to this presentation.
This afternoon, I want to
turn our minds towards home.
I have not -- your
own homes, I guess.
Although, I bet you probably just
thought of your own homes just now.
But I want us to contemplate
instead how the powerful idea
of home drives the artificial
forging of a post-conflict context
that encourages refugee return
with implications for
their reintegration.
And so, this afternoon, we'll
be looking at the reintegration
of refugees in post-conflict
Liberia specifically,
but I will focus my talk on the
local and global intersections
in the ways these refugees forage
home in the Liberian context.
My paper is based on qualitative
research that I carried in
and on Liberia between
2006 and 2012,
in which I employed a
triangulation of methods,
in-depth interviews were
conducted with 100 refugee women,
government officials, staff of
international and local agencies,
community leaders, and other
members of civil society.
And these were supplemented
with non-participant observation
and documentary review.
I visited five of Liberia's
15 counties to collect data
for my research and four of these
five counties I visited were the
areas of highest return of refugees.
Participants were located
through snowballing and they came
from various backgrounds
and various experiences.
I collected documents not
just from Liberia but also
from Geneva during my
post-doctoral time there.
And I was able to also do some
intersubjective validation
of my data by speaking with
refugee expats, not just in Liberia
and outside Liberia but in Geneva.
The UN [inaudible] --
at the headquarters of the
United Nations High Commission
for Refugees Office there.
So, this is the basis for some
of the statements I'll
be making this afternoon.
Let me also quickly say
that my analysis is informed
by a constructivist view of
international politics relying
on Alexander Wendt's critique of the
so called structure agents problem
in international relations by
which international anarchy
and structure are deemed to
be the major determinants
of international politics
instead, of course,
Wendt posits that this system is
one in which various actors --
which we will call agents here --
play significant roles
in determining structure
and are themselves in turn,
modified by structure.
This is important for
my own analysis here
because it helps me recognize
that there are various --
there is in existence
various actors --
from the local to the global
operator within the domain
of post-conflict reintegration.
And this makes it possible
for also --
acknowledge also, the roles of
women in their reintegration
because their narratives
are often buried
in the masculinist interpretation
of international processes
such as this one.
This framework also
makes it possible
to admit the constraining conditions
which international structure places
on the activities of the various
agents we'll be mentioning
in this paper.
But at the same time, it
brings to relief the ways
in which these agents
and actors contracts
or forge their desired outcomes.
In this case, the idea
of home in Liberia --
whether consciously
or unconsciously.
I will not bore you with definitions
because we know who refugees are.
They're eligible basically
for international protection
under international law.
And this is because national
protection has failed them.
And one of the responsibilities
of the international community
to refugees is to find durable
solutions to their problems.
And the three solutions that have
been applied over the decades
that the international
refugee has evolved, of course,
are repatriation -- that is
return of refugees to the country
of origin; integration
which involves helping them
to acquire a new citizenship
in the country of asylum;
and resettlement with
a third country.
My focus is on repatriation and
voluntary repatriation has become --
in quotes -- "The most desirable
solution for refugee problems"
and has been promoted vigorously
by the United Nations High
Commissioner for Refugees -- UNHCR.
And, in fact, the 1990s
were described
as the decade of repatriation.
The 2000s were referred
to the new era of return.
And so, repatriation -- in fact,
repatriation has become the
buzz word in the last two,
three decades in refugee
and states practice.
Reintegration is supposed to proceed
concomitantly or after repatriation
and it is a process that is expected
to result in the disappearance
of differences in legal
rights and duties
between returnees and
their compatriots.
In this paper, I am not --
I am going to focus on the idea
of home, like I said earlier,
because it's been noted that
one of the chief incentives
for refugees return to
the country of origin is
to recover a sense
of feeling at home.
I have taken the task of home to
task because of the home to task
in one of my previous papers
where I argued that the illusion
of home leads to a partial illusion
of peace among returnee women.
And, therefore, because of
that return may not be
sustainable in certain instances.
Today, the questions that
I will be looking at relate
to how do Liberian refugees
returning from exile
from various west African
countries encounter the country they
return to.
In what ways do these returnees --
as members of various communities
and localities -- invent, shape,
and forage a home for themselves
to enable sustainable reintegration?
What complimentary rules do local
and international agencies bear
in either particularistic
of global mandates play
in these processes
with what outcomes?
And I'm going to argue that refugees
and returnees are not merely victims
of circumstances nor mere
wards of the national
and international system.
Rather they are veritable
agents in constructing
or forging the home they return to.
We further contain here that the
returnees' perception of the country
of origin as home, as well as their
steady progress towards the touted
ideal of home, is significantly
shaped
by the intersecting activities
of various local, national,
and international agencies
and [inaudible].
And so, I am going to --
In this presentation,
look at these --
I will begin by provided
international
and specific Liberian context
and then look at the actuals
that are involved in this process
of forging or shaping home,
as well as the points of
intersection between the local
and the international agencies
and actors in the Liberian case.
And then conclude with the
statements on what these means
for the process of forging home.
Within the global context
between 1991 and 1996,
repatriation numbers
increased globally.
Over one million refugees
returned to Ethiopia and Eritrea.
About 1.7 million Mozambican
refugees returned
from several neighboring countries.
More than 2.7 million
Afghans returned from Pakistan
and Iraq and so on and so forth.
However, the trend
turned by the mid-2000s.
official figures from country of
asylum and origin data indicate
that there has been a decline in
repatriation worldwide by 2014.
Repatriation was reported
to be at a 30-year low.
The lowest since 1983 was
recorded at just 126,800 refugees.
Which was, again, significantly
lower than the year before that.
These figures are from the UNHCR.
Significantly, however, of
the eight countries accounted
for 95% of returns in 2015.
Six of these countries
are African countries.
And so, the fate of
these refugees returning
to sometimes unstable transitional
context is an important subject
of study.
Liberia is a country that's had
what we'll call relative peace
for 133 years until the so-called
rice riots of 1980 [inaudible]
in the governments of Samuel Doe --
the military governments
of Samuel Doe.
Which led to a decade of
crisis in that country.
And then, an insurgency that started
in 1989, of which the reports
of the Liberian Truth and
Reconciliation Commission says --
and I quote -- "Quickly degenerated
into a rebellion without a cause.
At one point, a seven
cornered fight as represented
by seven distinct warring factions,
engaged in a full blown
fratricidal civil war."
At the height of the
14-year civil war in Liberia,
several hundred thousand
Liberians fled
to neighboring countries
in a single year.
It is estimated that in the cause
of the war, between 1989 and 2003,
three quarters of the 3 million
strong Liberian population became
either refugees or
internally displaced.
And that's a very big number.
It's also estimated by
the government of Liberia
that an approximate 10%
of the population died
in the cause of that war.
By the end of the civil war in
2003, the country was in ruins.
All critical infrastructures
were destroyed.
The economy was in shambles
with productive capacity
almost entirely depleted.
Unemployment was estimated
to be over 80%.
These are figures from
the Government of Liberia.
And this was the dire situation
to which refugees began to return
at the end of the war in 2003.
It took from about 2003
to 2012 -- thereabout --
for the majority of refugees
from neighboring countries
to make their way back
to Liberia as returnees
to their country of origin.
Now, the comprehensive
peace accords that ended
that war says something --
specifies that the national --
and I'm quoting from the Accra
Comprehensive Peace Accord.
It's ethical [inaudible]
Sections 1a to c.
That the National Transitional
Government of Liberia,
with the assistance of the
International Community,
shall design and implement a
plan for the voluntary return
and reintegration of
Liberian refugees
and internally displaced
persons, including non-combatants,
in accordance with international
conventions, norms, and practices.
And I highlight this to show
that post-conflict order
that was designed for Liberia,
intimately embraced the rule
of international community, working
with the government of Liberia
to construct a society that would
be conducive to the restoration
of livelihood and dignity
for displaced persons
and returning refugees.
How the returnees have
come to Liberia as home.
And whenever I used home in
this presentation, there is --
a double quotation mark around it to
indicate that it remains a concept
that I personally struggle
with and that many
of our respondents
also struggle with.
And do not agree on how the
returnees encounter Liberia as home.
Majority of my respondents
in interviews indicated
that they fled Liberia because
of fear -- fear for their lives,
for their families,
for their safety.
And, of course, the most
cited reason for returning
to the country was the end of
the war and the opportunity
to participate in elections.
Many of them indicated that they
also wanted to return to Liberia
for what we call "push" reasons.
In other words, they felt pushed
out of the countries of exile
for various reasons including
suffering or unbearable conditions.
People being cruel to them.
These are their own words.
Idleness and lack of
work in the camps
or because United Nations
High Commissioner
for Refugees said they
should return.
Or because they lost
family members in exile.
Or because the options
for resettlement was
not working for them.
Apparently, the search for
home was partly occasioned
by the returnees' experiences
in exile which were antithetical
to their place of comfort
thereby propelling the refugees
to desire a better place.
A place where they could
recover a sense of belong,
of worth, and of dignity.
All the returnees I interviewed
refer to Liberia as home.
At least once in the conversation.
And some, several times
over and over again.
However, the political, social, and
economic situations of the country
in the post-conflict
period are the challenges
of reintegration were daunting
for these newly returned refugees.
I will examine now the way in
which reintegration is forged
or constructed by various actors.
Many returnees, as I said earlier,
returned because wants
the feeling of home.
And whenever that sense
of home is absent
or expected socio-economic
dividends are not attained,
reintegration becomes uncertain.
Laura Hammond, who worked with
Ethiopian returnees opined
that home is associated with
community and circumstance rather
than with a fixed geographical
space.
Liisa Malkki who studied Hutu
refugees in Tanzania posited
that refugees identify
themselves based
on certain socio-personal identities
such as gender, ethnicity, and age.
And these are the factors
that eventually determines
one's connection to a place
and eventually, one's reintegration
in the country of origin.
What this authors affirm --
and by which I confirm --
some of my observations is that
return to a geographical location
of memory and nostalgia is
an insufficient condition
for the reintegration of returnees.
Other realities of existence play
key roles in determining the ability
of former refugees to
settle down and thrive.
In the Liberian case on this study
from interviews with agency staff
and from review of documents, we
identified a plethora of actors
that were involved in the
reintegration of refugees
and has shift the process
in significant ways.
I group these into four: the
national - the governmental actors
or agencies; international actors;
community based actors;
and individuals.
The most prominent of these was
the Liberian government itself.
The chief government agency
with the responsibility
for Liberian returnees was the
Liberian Refugee Repatriation
and Resettlement Commission
-- LRRRC.
We call it the L-triple
R-C, and it had offices
in all the returnee
areas and was created
by an act of parliament in 1993.
Its mandate covers refugees from all
over Liberia, as well as returnees
to Liberia, as well as
internally displaced persons.
Their main goal is to ensure
repatriation is safety and dignity.
And so, they partner with UNHCR
and other agencies that work
with bringing refugees
back to the country.
And role of this government agency,
according to the program officer
for repatriation, is to create
a conducive atmosphere free
from harassment and other problems
and to ensure repatriation
in safety and dignity.
And they perform various
tasks towards this end.
Now, we know that the majority of
refugees -- we know this for a fact,
women and children -- and so we were
interested in finding the role of --
looking for what aspect of
government is responsible
for attending to their
needs as returnees.
Now the Minister of Gender
and Development, we found,
was playing an active role
in charting the post-war
position of Liberian women.
They convened a national gender
based violence task force
that was a platform for interagency
coordination for all the agencies
that work with Liberian women,
including women returnees.
And this task force, we found --
I did attend some of the meetings
of the task force -- had expended
a lot of efforts to produce,
for example, a simplified version of
Liberia's ground breaking rape law.
And they also had created
a monthly reports and form
for documenting cases of
gender based violence --
GBV -- across the country.
In other -- now the accents of
implementation of these kinds
of policy instruments is a
separate matter by itself.
The Ministry of Gender also
officially celebrates the United
Nation's declared 16
days of activism
against violence, against women.
That's between November
25 and December 10,
thereby linking Liberian
women's struggles
with global women's struggles.
We found this GBV task
force replicated
in other countries that I visited.
I attended a meeting
again in Lofa County.
I found that the efforts
that were being promoted
in the capital were also
being promoted and replicated
in the counties which
was indeed had need.
Another agency that I find
relevant to our discussion
of the post-conflict context for
Liberian returnees is Liberia Agency
for Community Empowerment.
L-A-C-E. LACE.
And this organization was
specifically born out of the need
for funds for post-war
rehabilitation of infrastructure.
In spite of the constraints
of external indebtedness
that made this initially difficult
for the Liberian Government
to benefit from the
World Bank's programs.
According to government records,
the Liberian Government defaulted
on its debts in the mid-1980s.
And by 2006, external debts had
soared to 4.5 billion U.S. dollars.
Which was equivalent of
800% of the country's GDP.
And the equivalent
of 3000% of exports.
It was because of this that the LACE
was established in 2004 by an act
of parliament to administer
a $6-billion grant
from the World Bank.
And the agencies mandates, in
the words of the program manager,
was community driven development
through community empowerment.
And because these are the
communities that refugees return to,
I was interested in
the activities of LACE.
And one final government agency
I just mention, is the truth --
I would say was the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission
of Liberia, the TRC,
which the Chairperson said
to me was created specifically
to promote national healing
and national empathy.
Because Truth, according to him, is
the [inaudible] of reconciliation.
We know that return to post-conflict
context includes the capacity
of citizens to live
together in peace once again.
And so, the work of the TRC was
one of those that we explored.
International agencies, of course,
the most important was the UNHCR.
Everywhere I went in Liberia,
the UNHCR was visible.
And their activities could be seen.
As a matter of fact,
the UNHCR seemed
to be the most authoritative
structure of governance
on the ground in many of
the counties that I visited.
Even before organized repatriation,
before the government came to some
of these places, the UNHCR was
there preparing those counties
for the return of refugees
from neighboring countries.
So, the agency was
engaged in several --
not just reintegration activities
or repatriation activities,
but some governance functions too.
Providing health, education,
agriculture, shelter,
and several other functions.
The United Nations Mission
in Liberia was another agency
that we engaged with
and saw the activities.
And I want to mention here,
just one of the many NGOs
that we found acting
also on the ground,
the International Rescue Committee,
which specifically had
extensive programs for women.
Established women's centers,
women's department programs,
women's resources [inaudible]
and did psycho-social counselling
with women which was a very, very
rare activity amongst other NGOs.
At the committee level,
we interviewed committee
and religious leaders, youth
leaders, women leaders,
but specifically, I'll
mention one here.
One group here.
The District Development
Committees which were created
by the United Nations Development
Program, the UNDP, and the Ministry
of Internal Affairs to bring power,
in quotes, to the grassroots.
And their job was to
monitor projects carried
out by various agencies, evaluate
and report on these projects
to ensure accountability, as well as
receive information from the people
in the communities about their
needs and channel these to the UNDP.
Ultimately, however, reintegration,
however conceived, is personal.
In other words, it is the returnee
refugee's participation in his
or her own reintegration
that determines the
outcome for each person.
While local and international
agencies may expend efforts towards
creating conducive
conditions in the resource,
most exercise the prerogative
to return voluntarily
to access reintegration program
and to achieve the full exercise
of the rights and dignities
lost to them as exiles of war.
Now I'll quickly look at the global
-- how the global and the local meet
in this process of forging
home before I conclude.
I have tried to skip a lot of talks
so that we can have
time to still discuss.
Refugee experience has
shown that home cannot,
and does not have exactly
the same dictionary meaning
to returning refugees.
One, nostalgia may invoke the
traditional expectation of home,
reintegration experiences are potent
for shifting these expectations
and act towards or further
away from the ideal.
Here, in this section, I'm going
to [inaudible] process of shaping.
Perhaps the process of invasion
or imitation of the institutional,
material, and ideational reference
of home in post-conflict Liberia
by both local actors and
international agencies.
The first point here is that the
very discourse on return, on home,
reintegration, rights of
refugees, and the desirability
of repatriation, that very discourse
is shift by international norms,
processes, actors, and regimes
that leave little or no room
for initiative of the individual.
And I give -- I explained this --
when the human security framework
was popularized by the UNDP
in the early 1990s, the UNHCR
defined reintegration in terms
of human security as the process
by which returnees achieve,
and I quote, "a progressively
greater degree of physical, social,
legal, and material security."
When the human security framework
came under critique by said actors,
the UNHCR redefined reintegration
using human rights discourse
as legisumation [phonetic].
And so, reintegration -- by 2004,
came to be defined by the UNHCR
as a process that should result in
the disappearance of differences
in legal rights and duties between
returnees and their compatriots.
And, of course, these frames are
basically imposed on the discourse
on refugee reintegration as
refugees are rarely, if ever,
involved in firm and
durable solutions
at the conceptualization level.
The overbearing role of
the UNHCR in this process
of norming [phonetic] is
worthy of [inaudible].
Many of our research participants
stated categorically that,
while in the refugee camps,
the UNHCR was instrumental
to painting the picture of a
desirable home in Liberia in order
to encourage them to repatriate.
In a fated dance, state actors
in post-conflict situations
replicate this idea and insist
on repatriation mainly
for political reasons.
Because the success of
return and reintegration
of refugees is deemed a powerful
endorsement of the [inaudible]
regime. So, the governments of these
newly post-conflict states then hand
down this conception of the
desirability of these norms.
Especially here with reference
to repatriation of refugees
through their legislatures --
meaning that they make relevant laws
and thereby create institutions
through the implementing agencies
of government, through
local governance structures
which are questioningly perpetuated
these constructs of home.
Together, these global and local
forces then weave the ideational
context for return and [inaudible]
to take place forging what is
sometimes a false sense of security.
It is obvious that these ideas need
to be purveyed by certain agents
which in their function
and apply these norms
and ideas and bring them to life.
A And this is the second point here.
The very determination
of actors or agencies
which eventually forge
the reintegration context
for refugees is also jointly
achieved by international forces,
national governments,
and local actors.
And I give a few examples.
It is a vote of the United
Nations Security Council
that establishes a
peace keeping mission
such as United Nations mission
in Liberia which became critical
to reestablishing security
in that country.
And establishing stability
and democratic governance.
The UNHCR -- which occupies a
unique position among UN agencies --
Is another important one.
It is the executive committee of
the UNHCR that determines the extent
of the organizations involvement
in specific areas during its scope
and which, as politically
and oppressionally
[phonetic] expedient...
one refugee scholar says, and
I quote very clearly, well,
very carefully, that successive
high commissioners quickly realize
that in order to have any impact
on the world political arena,
they have to use the power
of their expertise, ideas,
strategies, and legitimacy.
To author -- the information
and value context
in which states made policy.
The office of the UNHCR has tried to
project refugee norms in to a world
of politics dominated by states.
For most of its history,
the office has acted
as a teacher of refugee norms.
UNHCR not only acted as the
transmitter of refugee norms
but also socialize new states
to accept the promotion
of refugee norms domestically
as part of the common members
of the international community.
These decisions at that global level
are then replicated at national,
community, and local levels.
In the Liberian case on the study,
for example, the government set
up its own refugee agency,
the LRRRC to parallel and work
with the UNHCR's objectives.
When the UNDP required
community structures to work,
the government set up the
District Development Committees.
When the World Bank needed a
credible agency outside the corrupt
machineries of government
to administer new loans,
then the government
also created the LACE --
the Liberian Agency for
Community Empowerment.
Those we see here -- a persistent,
concurrent, and concomitant machine
of global intentions and actors
with local desires and agents
to forge the reintegration
context for returning refugees.
The third instance I'm
going to mention here --
that's the penultimate one -- is the
conjoining of local and global agent
in constructing reintegration
concerns especially with respect
to the determination of projects
of importance to be implemented.
The data we have shows
that a lot of times,
the local communities are invited
to participate in the activities
of these various international
and government agencies
by suggesting projects
to be implemented.
But we found that a lot of
times -- in most cases --
the role of these local agents
did not include envisioning
and program design.
The fourth and final dimension
I just want to mention here
of this local and global
intersections
in the reintegration context is
a bit positive because we found,
in almost every county
that I visited, that --
we found specific instances
of global level actors working
through international benedictions
and governments collaborator
with local groups to provide
reintegration services.
So, whereas, it was difficult
to include them in the selection
of projects because those are --
[inaudible] driven and
politically driven sometimes.
The global meets the local in the
Liberian context most effectively
and most positively in the
implementation of projects.
And we found several
examples of certain projects.
One of the most common that the
UNHCR used, not just in Liberia
but around the world, were the
community empowerment projects.
But I found one and I
wanted to just mention here,
the Voinjama District Women
Organization for Peace
and Development which was a
program in the Lofa county area
of Liberia founded by the UNHCR --
both managed by the women in
that committee themselves.
And it was free for all
participants and they found this --
the assessed that it was
useful for their reintegration.
I will conclude at this time...
My paper has explored intersections
between global and local agencies
in constructing the
[inaudible] ideal of home
for returning refugees to Liberia.
International norms are
created and handed down.
Various actors are created to
participate in the application
of these norms and deliberate action
is taken by global and local actors
who collaborate on the
selection and implementation
of reintegration projects.
The outcome of these processes
for the reintegration
of refugees is two-fold.
Home becomes no more than a
fabrication for some and for some,
it remains a goal to be attained.
If home is a fabrication, a
product artificially constructed
by the interflow of the
various ideas, norms,
and actors both originating and
present in the country of return,
that means that returnees must
work for their reintegration
by taking decided actions, decisions
for creating the home
that they desire.
If home is destination,
then it means that returnees
themselves must strive
for that ideal.
That destination they
refer to as home.
Because the home they remember,
usually, with time blunted nostalgia
from the pre-conflict
period no longer exists.
And the home they fled from during
the war, of course, was undesirable.
And the home that they encounter
when they return is
not really perfect.
And so, these former exiles who are
stripped of options in most cases,
must continue to forge
ahead steadily
but surely towards that destination.
A place of comfort called home.
If they must achieve
their ideals again
because as Bill Bryson puts
it, "once you leave home,
you can't go home again."
And these implications
for the many refugee
and returnee repatriation
context around the globe today.
I want to thank everyone
for listening.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Angel Batiste: Thank you so much
for this rich, scholarly
contribution.
As was noted earlier, this is
a topical issue facing several
countries at this point in time.
So, we thank you for your
contribution to this topic.
At this point, we will open
up for question and answer.
Before I --
Your questions [inaudible],
I'd like to note
that this program is being webcast.
And in asking a question, you are
giving permission to be webcast.
At this point, let's
open for questions.
[Inaudible comment]
>> Is there a situation in which
committees or refugees are set
up to determine what it is
that they need and they want
because very often someone
coming from across the globe
and who has been in another part
of the world may not really
understand what is needed
to recreate a home or build a new
home or to integrate [inaudible].
So, is there now -- are there
committees [inaudible] in order
to design projects for the
reintegration of refugees?
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso: Thank
you very much for that question.
Usually in the camps, there are
committees, the refugee leadership
and various groups of
refugees are represented
in consultations before there
are mass repatriation movements
like those to Liberia
at the end of a war.
And to a large extent,
what we find is
that while these refugees
are consulted and included
in the processes of repatriation,
and eventually reintegration,
there is not much initiative left
to the refugees beyond the
decision to repatriate.
In fact, in many instances in Africa
-- including the Liberian case --
there were camps in West Africa,
and I will mention specifically
in Ghana housing Liberian
refugees for instance,
why the refugees did not want
to return at the end of the war,
and the UNHCR cajoled, the
government of Ghana cajoled,
and eventually, had to
view the [inaudible] stick,
like the Kenyan Government
is doing right now
by closing the largest
refugee camp in Ghana.
So, all we find is that what --
rather, refugees might
have their preferences,
might have their own
ideas of what they want,
the fact is that the governments
and the international agencies tend
to have their way more often
than the refugees have their way.
And I think that's just
what I've seen about that.
[inaudible] what is the best
approach to that perhaps would be
that at the conceptualization level
then, refugees need to be involved.
And that way, their voices
are entirely missing.
They are not involved in the laws --
in making the policies
that involves them.
Or in the agencies --
in the government structures of
the agencies that work with them.
And so, they are simply included
at the stage of implementation
of those policies and that's
where the problem lies.
[Inaudible comment]
Yes. Yes.
Thank you very much.
If there's anything I'm saying,
really, it is that the idea
of home has nothing -- has
-- I'm not saying nothing.
Has little to do with
geographical space.
Meaning that refugees can find
home even outside their countries
of citizenship.
They can find home like
some have found in Ghana
and refuse to go back to Liberia.
And so, home then has to be defined
by all of several other references
that helps them --
like you rightly put --
and which is a phrase the
UNHCR uses all the time.
Define safety.
Define dignity.
And so, that's home.
So, why do I need to go back
to a post-conflict context
where safety is not guaranteed,
and dignity is not guaranteed.
And that's something that
some refugees grapple with.
Thank you.
>> I'm interested actually in
something I'm -- it's actually --
I have a follow up question
on the first question.
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso: Okay.
>> I mean, sure, repatriation --
repatriazation [phonetic] is the
idea course, I understand that.
But refugees don't leave
for simple reasons.
I mean, it's always complex.
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso:
That's correct.
[Inaudible comment]
That's right.
>> What guarantees are there when
these people are crossed, I mean,
return -- that their safety
is guaranteed, for example.
I mean, in the case of civil
war, maybe they're discriminated
against [inaudible] ethnicity,
it could be political views.
Now, you're voicing that the return
and the UN is saying
[inaudible] guaranteed that.
But maybe the opposite side won.
I mean, [inaudible].
How can you guarantee their safety?
How can you guarantee
their [inaudible]?
I mean, what steps are taken
in [inaudible] for example.
The UN can only stay
there for so long.
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso:
Thank you so much.
You have just highlighted the
other issues that I didn't bring
into this paper but I have
engaged with in other publications.
The fact that there are
no guarantees especially
in the immediate return context.
Over the years, certainly,
the governments
in the post-conflict
country can acquire capacity,
can become stronger, and
its reach gradually extends
to the various parts of the country
where it's [inaudible]
have not been true.
And then, there's also the problem
you mentioned that sometimes,
the "enemy" -- in quotes -- is still
alive and well in the communities
that these refugees return to.
And nobody is doing
anything about that.
And that was one of the
concerns of refugees either --
outside Liberia who were still
refugees in Nigeria a while back.
And sometimes, there's not
much the government can do.
In the case of Liberia, may of the
so-called enemies were, and are,
holding powerful positions in
government, in their counties.
And there's nothing these
refugees can do about that.
It's either they refuse to
return or they just submit --
as some just said to me in
Liberia, they are still afraid,
but where else can they go?
They lack choices.
And many did mention that other
solutions such as integrations --
local integration elsewhere --
or resettlement were
not available to them.
So, returning to Liberia was
because they had no choice.
So, in that context, the
government -- as I said, usually,
eventually develops capacity to deal
with the harder psychosocial aspects
of return, including
safety and dignity.
And the restoration of rights
to people across the land.
But in the immediate context, which
I saw, it was extremely difficult.
The international agencies,
I would say,
especially in the Liberian
context, were doing a great job.
The UN mission in Liberia
was everywhere.
The UNHCR, like I said,
Where the government was
absent, they were present.
But again, their mandates are
quite specific which, again,
means that there isn't much they can
do but their presence seemed to --
in many instances, make
the returnees feel a bit,
like, they were home.
And they also expressed exactly
the same worry that you expressed.
When the [inaudible] of
the UN mission Liberia --
when it leaves, what's
going to happen to us?
Many of them said this to me.
Really. And there's
nothing anyone can say
because the mission will leave.
They will have to grapple
with their own governments.
>> Another question over here.
[Inaudible comment]
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso:
Absolutely.
>> For instance, if you left
your country because of war,
and you're a refugee in another
country, and you're going back to --
[Inaudible comment]
>> Olajumoke Yacob-Haliso:
Thank you very much for that.
I won't disagree with you.
And one of the -- I think, I
could say one basic fact is
that when refugees return
to a post-conflict context,
this situation in the country of
origin, at first, is usually worse
than the situation in the refugee
camps where they're coming from.
At least, [inaudible] the
country begins to recover.
What I found in Liberia is not
just because there were no economic
and order opportunities, it
was instead the expectations
of the refugees were too high
for a post-conflict context.
And so, they returned and they were
highly disappointed about the fact
that there were no
jobs, there were no --
even the queues the [inaudible].
There were not markets
for those queues.
And so many such problems.
So, I do understand.
I just see [inaudible]
speaking about what --
I also think that beyond appealing
to the international community,
the individuals, like I said in my
paper, as well as the communities --
where they came together, they
were able to achieve some things.
If there were more instances of
their coming together to articulate
and find solutions, there would
have been better prospects
of reintegration.
But what we found instead was
a predisposition, in some case,
to what I would call
"Aids dependence"
and which has negative
consequences too.
Just to give you another
side of that.
Thank you.
[Inaudible comment]
Well, thank you very much.
There are studies.
But frankly speaking,
one of the justifications
for my research has been that there
are very few in-depth case studies
that show what's happening in a
particular country over the years
which is what, I think,
I'm trying to do really.
Following this particular case
since I started following
in 2006 until now.
And for Liberia, for instance,
I found just one other study.
A 2011 study that tried
to also look at some
of the issues that I looked at.
Not many. And I found for, maybe,
Angola and a few other
countries -- Columbia.
A few other countries scattered
there but while there is a lot
of work on refugee issues by
scholars around the world,
I think we need more of an in-depth
look at each country's context
because in many instances,
context is everything
and not just the larger debates
that other scholars engage with.
So, I would join you in saying
that we need to know more.
The UNHCR itself, when I spoke with
expats that [inaudible] with us,
of course, through its own internal
processes tries to track the results
of what they are doing
systematically.
And because of that, I have
actually come to believe
that it's probably one of
the most dynamic UN agency
because it's more able to
adapt and change quickly
to emergent situations in its
activities around the world.
And, that's all.
Thank you.
>> Angel Batiste: Thank
you very much.
[ Applause ]
Again, thank you for
joining us today.
Thank you to our speaker.
And I'd like to invite you to join
the African Section on October 27th.
We'll have the imminent
historian, Dr. Toyin Falola,
who is in the audience
today -- speaking.
So, we hope to see you on the 27th.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.